welcome to simply learns deep learning
frameworks my name is Richard Kirchner
with the simply learned team that's www
I'm get certified get a hat let's cover
some of the big players in deep learning
today and deep learning is just so
exciting this is the forefront of our
machine learning and artificial
intelligence and where it's at as far as
the cutting edge and what's coming next
that doesn't mean ignore all the machine
learning tools because certainly they've
been around a long time and are a basis
for a lot of deep learning platforms
along with solving the more basic
problems but deep learning is the
cutting edge it is the one that's
finding new solutions to things we never
thought were solvable before and today
we're gonna look at just a quick look at
tensorflow probably the biggest package
out there right now chorus which is
probably one of the biggest growing
packages out there right now
pi torch piano dl forge a cafe chain ER
and the c NT k now all these packages
Center on deep learning and neural
networks if you haven't studied our
neural networks and how they function
send a note down below in the YouTube
video and we'll post some more
information or one of our other videos
just so you have an idea what deep
learning is but let's go ahead and dive
in let's take a look at tensor flow and
as we look at these things I want you
also to notice that a lot of this
overlaps you'll see companies are
investing in all of these different
products to see where they go so these
are all huge players no matter where
you're coming from so let's look at
tensor flow tensor flow was developed by
Google brain team it supports languages
both Python and R that's a big you'll
see Python is probably one of the
biggest players in the data science
neural networks across all the packages
that doesn't discount in the other ones
certainly a lot of these packages like
tensor flow you can set up an interface
into Java and other places but it was
designed and has a very high
functionality in both Python and R and
you uses data flow graph to process data
this is nice because as you build these
neural networks you can actually look at
how the data flows through the neural
network they're easy to build machine
learning models robust machine learning
production powerful experimentation for
research
I can't even emphasize that enough it's
very easy to go in there and switch a
couple of lines in your tensor flow set
up to try out a new set up a new neural
network to see how it works with your
data going through and if it gives you
better results tints our board for data
visualization and this is another huge
package that people kind of forget as
part of tensor flow put out by Google
brain team and tensor flow is now open
source the tensor flow data
visualization is makes it so quick and
easy to put out your data for visual
effects when you're working with your
CEO or with your shareholders and of
course you can use both the r and python
visualization packages to since you're
usually running it in Python or R let's
go ahead and talk about cross we
mentioned overlapping earlier cross is
probably the most overlapping package
out there and I'll show you why in just
a minute let's start with the creator of
cross or the founder now cross was
originally developed by Francois Chile
he's the author of cross and it has over
350,000 users and 700 plus open source
contributors that's big cross is
tensorflow might be the biggest or well
most well-known package out there cross
because it overlaps so many other areas
and is such a high ended development is
probably the fastest growing package out
there right now and it's got a
high-level neural network API written in
Python so for us python lovers and data
science a great package to go from there
what makes it interesting is it runs on
top of tensorflow
piano C and TK so it uses their neural
networks underneath and then you use
your definition and chorus to define all
these packages so now if you're running
tensorflow and you put cross on top of
it you have both the benefits of cross
and all the tools and tensorflow this is
why cross is the fastest growing neural
network or deep learning package out
there it is used in several startup
research labs and companies Microsoft
Research you'll see Microsoft is
invested in all of these now so any
place you have any of these coming out
Microsoft as part of it and course
Microsoft with the C and TK is their
package and they're highly invested in
that Netflix NASA CERN are all using
cross for using their data
processing their deep learning it's
user-friendly as it offers simple API
sand provides clear and actionable
feedback upon user error provides
modularity as a sequence of a graph of
stand-alone fully configurable modules
it can be plugged together with as few
restrictions as possible these two
things makes it so easy to write a cross
code a lot of times you might be messing
with tensorflow and you turn around you
can do the same cross code in a few
lines or let you know it's significantly
less than you'd write the same code in
tensorflow
so you could use chorus on top of
tensorflow and cross it's easily
extensible as a new modules are simple
to add this feature makes cross suitable
for advanced research
so from course we're gonna go into PI
torch
and it's authored by Adam Pasque Sam
gross assume it's con Tala and Gregory
Shannon lua based scientific computing
framework for machine learning and deep
learning algorithms so this is coming
from the scientific teams they took in
there you can guess it's PI so it's in
Python but it's based on the scientific
computing and so they're looking at
answers for science and it employed CUDA
along with C C++ libraries for
processing was designed to scale the
product of building models and overall
flexibility if you're a C C++ programmer
and that's your programmer programming
of choice you can see why PI torch might
be really big jump for you because you
know the backend and you can get in
there and see what's going on with that
particular framework and it's widely
used in companies like Facebook Twitter
Google and you find this interesting
because Google like I said you'll see
microsoft and google has their hands in
all of these and I'm guessing that
Facebook and Twitter have probably
investigated the best use and use these
different frameworks depending on what
they're working on so it provides a
flexibility and speed due to its hybrid
front-end enable scalable distributed
training and performance optimization
and research and production using torch
distributed back-end deep integration
into Python allows popular libraries and
packages to be used for clear ighting
neural network layers in Python so
remember has got that dual layer so if
you're running in C+ or C great language
and you can skip over to Python then
there's Theon oh and I had to look this
up how to pronounce it even though I
played with it
I've only read the word I've never heard
someone
say it I finally went in there looked it
up in just the a nope there's a lot of
pronunciations they know and different
things so see a no it's developed by the
université de montréal and it's written
in Python and really centers on NVIDIA
so you have your integration there to
your gps's which is huge you'll see the
GPS modules like in tensorflow there's a
GPS module in there and in chorus
obviously since it sits on tensorflow
most of these that's where they're going
is the GPS can process so much faster
than a CPU so the Python library that
allows to define optimize and evaluate
mathematical expressions involving
multi-dimensional arrays efficiently so
we look at this we have numpy siano has
a tight integration with numpy for data
computations so if you're a major Python
lover and you love the numpy which is
you know the number of python such a
central aspect of python and data
science num peas a way to go and then it
uses a GPUs to perform data intensive
computations which are much faster than
on a CPU and it has extensive unit
testing and self verification that can
detect and diagnose many types of errors
so Cianna is a pretty solid package and
the fact is written in Python and it's
designed pretty solid on the GPU makes
it a very big contender in our deep
learning array of platforms out there
and then we have deep learning for Java
or the DL for usually call it deal forge
a deep learning for Java it was
developed by a machine learning group
led by Adam Gibson a wonderful group I
got to meet him there they're a lot of
fun it's written in Java and skaila and
that is big if you are working in big
data and the Hadoop and the SPARC
framework those should jump out at you
right off the bat
so we have our DL 4j supports different
neural networks like CNN RN and LST M
CNN is your convolutional neural network
are it n is your recurrent neural
network and LST M is your long
short-term memory for the neural network
so you'll see CN n lsdm a convolutional
neural network with a long short-term
memory it's connected to the Eclipse
Foundation so the DL for J was
contributed to Eclipse Foundation
integrated with Hadoop and Apache spark
I talked about that earlier since galas
spark is written in
Kailas and we're talking about big data
and big data processing that's a big
name to have on there and the fact that
a lot of Hadoop your MapReduce is based
in Java you can see the connection for
the DL for J and Big Data and so DL for
J brings AI to business environments for
use to distributed CPUs and GPUs and
right there distributed CPUs and GPUs so
this can be run across a huge cluster of
computers quite easily it's designed for
that so if you're working in SPARC and
you have a hundred computers set up on
different racks this would be a really
solid roll it out the doorway set up for
you so we provides a distributed
computing framework as training with DL
for J occurs in a cluster as we're
talking about cluster computations
includes an N dimensional array class
using nd for J that allows scientific
computing in Java and skaila offers a
vector space modeling and topic modeling
toolkit that is designed to handle large
text sets and perform in LP natural
language processing so we looked at DL
for J let's take a look at the Kafe
developed at Bayer that's Berkley
artificial intelligence research so
Berkley is at it again cafe stands for a
convolutional architecture for fast
feature embedding it's written in C++
within Python interface so again we have
another contender for people who work in
the C++ realm and want to be able to go
back and forth between that and python
generally used for image detection and
classification used in academic research
projects which makes sense this is
coming out of Berkley startup prototypes
and large-scale industrial applications
envision speech and multimedia and
really when you see vision speech and
multimedia all of these deep learning
are addressing these particular aspects
and more so it's not a big jump when you
talk about vision there is a little bit
there as far as which ones handle the
vision better because then you're doing
different matrixes you know you have an
XY plot coming in and that's a big deal
that's you see that in tensor flow
especially Caffe supports GPU and CPU
based acceleration computational kernel
libraries such as nvidia CU DNN and
intel MLK so it's integrated a little
bit more on the multiprocessor and the
GPU setups in there we're seeing that
all come together
most of the packages now while nvidia is
almost in all of these as far as a GPU
acceleration but we're starting to see
the other ones migrate in there it
offers a high speed can process over
sixty million images per day with a
single nvidia k forty GPU that's huge
sixty million images per day so when
you're training this thing and as you
spend a lot of time training and I mean
that's just huge that's amazing so let's
take a look at chain er chain er is one
of those that kind of I don't hear a lot
about but it's still a contender in our
set up in here it is developed by
preferred networks in collaboration with
IBM Intel Microsoft and NVIDIA and there
we see Nvidia again they've got their
hands and everything and so does Intel
Microsoft and IBM that's what puts this
at one of the top contenders it has such
a huge backing in the industrial world
it's written purely in Python
it runs on top of numpy and C you PI
Python libraries so that's
straightforward if you're like I said
most of stuff in our machine learning is
heading towards the Python environment
because it's so flexible it's currently
one of the top use setups in there and
the chain is written right on top of it
in Python and it provides a number of
extended libraries we have the chain or
MN and the chain or RL and the chain or
CV and you'll find in deep learning
these little abbreviations are so many
unless you're working with a specific
set up and you're running it I wouldn't
worry too much about memorizing all of
them you maybe get your flashcards out
but we have chain or MN which is
multiple nodes RL which is your
reinforced learning and CV which is your
computer vision library so your images
and so when you're working with with
chain er you definitely want to know
what those mean and as you dig in deeper
into it but these are they have tons of
extended libraries these are a few of
the libraries they have these are the
top ones that are used so it supports
CUDA computation it only requires a few
lines of code to leverage a GPU
there's our GPU which we're seeing
across the board on all of our different
neural networks and how they how they
apply that is important because some of
them do a better job than others it also
runs on multiple GPUs with little effort
so just by his name cheyna is designed
to sit it out there to the different
aspects and bring them back together
that's what
that's one of the reasons chainer is
being developed so provides various
network architectures including
feed-forward nets convey Nets recurrent
Nets and recursive nets and again now
we're started digging deep into the
neural networks in deep learning as
opposed to the different main players
and most of these cover different
aspects of these you have to really dig
deep to see where these go but changes
coming up and it's got some heavy
hitters backing it it has you know like
I said IBM Intel Microsoft and Nvidia
are part of the development team there
and we're getting down to the end here
we have our Microsoft CNT k developed by
Microsoft Research and the CNT K is a
deep learning framework that builds a
neural network as a series of
computational steps via directed graph
it supports interfaces such as Python
and C++ so again now we have one of the
nice things about this as you'll see
it's it's the interfaces are really
spread out so those are the two main
players with Python being the more
commonly used one but we're starting to
see C++ coming in there's a lot of
programmers out there who use C++ and
it's used mainly for our hand written
and you can see some examples here for
what it's used mainly for so it's
designed for speed and efficiency and
that's always that's a big thing because
neural networks just eat up so much
processing power for all the
calculations it takes to program them so
it's designed for speed and efficiency C
and T ke scales well and production
using GPUs but has limited support from
the community so again we have the big
hitters behind it Microsoft Research but
does not have a huge community support
yet it's supposed to both RN n and CN n
type of neural models capable of
handling image a nice picture of the guy
writing their handwriting and speech
recognition problems so that's a wrap we
covered a number of different models
here we dived a little bit into tensor
flow probably the biggest hitter out
there right now or the biggest name out
on the market we have cross probably the
biggest growing name out there since
it's able to leverage both tensor flow
and C an O and C and TK so it leverages
other different products underneath of
it we have the PI tours the theano the
DL 4j the cafe the chain ER and the C
and TK so this is exciting because all
of these packages people are jumping
back and forth
because one has the new tools out that
works on something and then somebody
else upgrades there so it works better
you know so up comes DL for J which
processes across huge pools of data
across huge Hadoop networks and then has
that Java interface and it's like okay
Wow that you can leverage a hundred
computers to train your neural network
across all this data because the
training is what takes up all the
resources and tensor flow comes well how
do we set that up the community under
tensorflow then builds their packages to
run their GPUs across multiple data and
you can see that these are just growing
with each other and kind of in their own
direction all at the same time so very
exciting very exciting cutting edge in
our artificial intelligence design and
machine learning so with that thank you
for joining us today
again it's simply learned w w simply
learn comm get certified get ahead feel
free to join us at our website if you
have additional questions or want more
resources we certainly have a whole
library of videos and resources we put
out over the years or you can post notes
in the YouTube video below we do have a
monitor that tracks those thank you for
joining us again today and happy
learning hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here